jetzt live aus Köln der Presseclub mit
Jörg Schönenborn
herzlich willkommen schön dass Sie dabei
sind an diesem Sonntagmittag der Krieg
in der Ukraine entfernt sich von uns
geographisch das Kriegsgeschehen
verlagert sich nach Osten und viele
Menschen haben auch nicht mehr das
unmittelbare Bedrohungsgefühl vom Anfang
des Krieges tatsächlich aber gehen die
Gräueltaten geht das Blutvergießen jeden
Tag weiter und Bilder wie die aus
mariopol oder aus Butcher führen uns
täglich nicht nur das Blutvergießen vor
Augen sondern auch die Ohnmacht die
Ohnmacht der zivilisierten
weltkriegsverbrechen zu verhindern wie
schon auf dem Balkan in Afghanistan in
Syrien in Tschetschenien stellt sich die
Frage können andere Länder mehr tun ist
ein Eingreifen ein verhindern möglich
ohne das ganze schlimmer zu machen am
Ende gar einen Atomkrieg auszulösen der
besten hat sich für Schritte entschieden
einer dieser Schritte war am Freitag in
Brüssel die NATO Verteidigungsminister
haben angekündigt dass sie jetzt mehr
und nicht mehr nur defensive Waffen
liefern wollen am gleichen Tag die EU
ein neues Sanktionspaket beschlossen und
der ukrainische Präsident selenski sagt
das reicht alles nicht wir brauchen mehr
von euch ist der Westen tatsächlich zu
mutlos zu zaghaft zu wenig hilfsbereit
oder ist das Vorgehen klug und bedacht
weil ein schnelles Ende des Krieges
ohnehin nicht möglich ist das ist unser
Thema heute im Presseclub schwere
waffenschärfere Sanktionen stoppt das
Putins Terror und ich freue mich auf
diese Gäste Dennis Yücel ist bei uns
Türkei Korrespondent der Welt und
Präsident des Deutschen pentzentrums
herzlich willkommen ich freue mich auf
Susanne Kölbel auslandsreporterin beim
Nachrichtenmagazin Der Spiegel herzlich
Willkommen an Liana fix sie ist
Publizistin und Politikwissenschaftlerin
bei der körperstiftung und Friedrich
Schmidt ist wieder bei uns politischer
Korrespondent der FAZ unter anderem für
Russland und Belarus Herr Schmid ich
habe es gesagt der Krieg entfernt sich
geografisch Rückzug aus Kiew ist ein
tolles Wort wie ist die Lage was
bedeutet das Rückzug neu Gruppierung was
erwartet uns aus ihrer Sicht ich glaube
schon dass es sich dabei um eine neue
Gruppierung handelt und mit nicht um
einen Rückzug ich glaube da erwartet uns
oder vielmehr natürlich die Ukraine eine
sehr blutige Schlacht jetzt zunächst um
den Donbass der Beschluss von kammertors
hat das ja jetzt auch gerade gezeigt es
wird sicherlich mehr solche Fälle geben
und ich glaube da droht erstmal eine
blutige Schlacht weil sie sicherlich
versuchen wollen da diese kampffähigen
Verbände der Ukrainer die ja da stehen
im Don Bass schon seit 2014
einzukesseln und aufzureiben wie ist
ihre Einschätzung Frau ist das
Schlimmste dieses Krieges nun hinter uns
oder steht es noch bevor nein das ist
überhaupt nicht hinter uns also es ist
ein Erfolg der Ukrainerin und Ukraine
gewesen dass sie die russische Armee
zurückschlagen konnten aber wir sollten
uns nicht einem kriegs-optimismus
hingeben wie in der Kreml am Anfang
dieses Krieges nämlich hatte nämlich zu
denken nun jetzt ist das Schlimmste
geschafft und jetzt sind die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine auf dem Weg zu
einem Sieg so wird das nicht sein
sie brauchen weiterhin Unterstützung
großer Stadt insbesondere auch die
ukrainische Rüstungsindustrie
angegriffen das heißt wenn wir nicht
einen Stellungskrieg sehen wollen ein
abnutzungskrieg der sich auf lange Zeit
hinzieht braucht die Ukraine weiterhin
Unterstützung technische was ist ihr
Blick drauf was wäre eine optimistische
was eine pessimistische Perspektive
wenn ich das bin ich vor noch was
anderes sagen darf
[Musik]
ein bisschen unhöflich ist mit deiner
Korrektur zu beginnen aber ich bin nicht
mehr Türkei Korrespondent der Welt da
gab es gewisse Komplikationen und
seither bin ich als Autor in Berlin
muss man das feststellen dass die
Ukraine dass die ukrainische Armee aber
auch die Ukraine und Ukraine Bürgerinnen
und Bürger das des Landes in einer Weise
das Land verteidigt haben die Ukraine
verteidigt haben wie die Bundesregierung
zum Beispiel offenbar ist nicht für
möglich gehalten hat und auch die
französische Regierung offensichtlich
für möglich gehalten hat und es gab ja
auch Kollegen von uns
im deutschen Medien auch woanders die
dem ukrainischen Präsidenten Zielinski
auch zurufen er möge doch bitte
kapitulieren weil das hat das besser
machen können und ich finde das muss man
erstmal festhalten dass die Ukraine das
ist ein großer Erfolg und dass die dass
die anderen Kiews nicht geklappt hat und
naja die optimistische Perspektive ist
natürlich dass das diese Erfolg sich
auch in anderen Stellen wiederholt und
die pessimistische ist so
naja das ist halt Cros nee das ist alle
Po nur die ich jetzt weil vermuten aber
vielleicht kann es noch schlimmer werden
weil das ist Protein so ganz kampflos
oder so ganz ohne widerstandslos mit der
sich vermutlich jetzt auch nicht
geschlagen gibt der wird jetzt nicht
sagen na gut dann dann klappt es halt
nicht dann lass ich's halt das glaube
ich eher weniger was ist ihre Annahme
über Potenz nächster Schritte wie geht's
weiter na es wurde ja schon gesagt von
Herrn Schmidt also die die die die
ziehen sich jetzt zurück die haben ganz
schwere Verluste gehabt also wenn ich
das mal sagen darf in den 20 Jahren Irak
und Afghanistan Krieg haben die
westliche die westliche Allianz glaube
ich 8000 tote gehabt die wenn ich das
richtig höre dann haben die Russen in
diesen sechs Wochen
15.000 tote Soldaten gehabt das ist mehr
als alle alles was wir was wir kennen
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg und
unfasslich mal drei wahrscheinlich mit
den verletzten haben die 60.000
verletzte verwundete tote gehabt also
die nehmen unglaubliche Verluste hin die
spielen offensichtlich auch keine Rolle
so was machen sie jetzt sie ziehen sich
zurück sie wurden nicht erfreut
aufgenommen wie sie es erwartet haben
als Befreier das ist natürlich eine
Demoralisierung wenn das solchen einer
solchen
Armee aber sie ziehen sich zurück
kopieren sich neu und werden jetzt von
schalkev offensichtlich von von von von
Norden wieder wieder rangeführt und ich
habe jetzt vorhin gerade eine Karte
gesehen wo die in drei verschiedenen
Stellen wohl angreifen werden um diese
Zangen diesen sogenannten Zangengriff zu
organisieren sie wollen also die Armee
die den Don Bass hält also wollen sie
einkesseln und
möglichst vernichtend schlagen also das
hört sich an wie
was ich was es gab immer so die
kesselstacht in halbe 45 es gab
Stalingrad also ich meine
großer Kriegsschauplatz ist Zweiten
Weltkrieges also dreimal von der
deutschen erobert von der Roten Armee
zurückerobert und wenn das noch mal und
wenn das gelingt dann haben wir dann
haben wir so viele Tote und so viele
also
Frau Fink hat vorher gesagt es geht
entweder darum dass das gelingt und dann
ist das katastrophal für die Ukraine
wenn es aber ihnen gelingt das zu halten
dann haben wir
dann haben wir diesen abnutzungskrieg
der auf beiden Seiten katastrophal ist
aber zumindest mal Zeit kauft in jedem
Fall brauchen die Ukraine Unterstützung
die Frage ist eigentlich mehr auch eine
logistische wie kriegt man die
eigentlich ran in so einer kurzen Frist
und davor vor diesem vor dieser Frage
stehen die im Moment bevor wir auf diese
Frage kommen die zentrale dieser Sendung
ist habe ich eine bitte noch um
Einschätzung also sie haben beschrieben
wie sich der Krieg jetzt
mutmaßlich nicht nur konzentriert
sondern möglicherweise noch grausamer
noch intensiver noch blutiger wird ist
damit die Sorge das Polen dass das
Baltikum angegriffen wird und damit die
NATO ganz unmittelbar beistandleisten
muss ist diese Sorge geringer geworden
Herr Schmidt Frau fix ich habe neulich
im Fernsehen einen sogenannten
Militärexperten gesehen also im
russischen Staatsfernsehen der hat
gesagt es wäre ein Leichtes diesen
landkorridor zur Exklave Kaliningrad im
früheren Königsberg zu machen weil das
doch alles viel einfacher sei als in der
Ukraine und so da müsste man einfach nur
durchmarschieren das wäre natürlich dann
der bündnisverein man muss dann sagen
das ist natürlich auch Propaganda und so
aber es ist natürlich nicht
auszuschließen andererseits wenn man
sich anguckt wie jetzt die Verluste sind
Frau Körbel hat sie ja gerade
beschrieben also es wäre schon seltsam
wenn sie in so einer Lage eine zweite
Front aufmachen also das würde dann doch
die Kriegsziele in der Ukraine die ja
unverändert da sind das Land unter
Kontrolle bringen auch wenn sie jetzt
sagen wir wollen erstmal den don- zu
befreien entnazifizieren
entmilitarisieren das würde diese von
Putin ausgegebenen Ziele doch sehr
gefährden deswegen glaube ich eigentlich
dass es sich erstmal auf die Ukraine
konzentriert und wir sehen ja auch
gleichzeitig dass die NATO ja auch
Schritte unternimmt und das ist glaube
ich die wichtigste Entwicklung um genau
das zu verhindern also Abschreckung
funktioniert ja nur dadurch dass die
andere Seite glaubhaft denkt dass sie
nicht gewinnen kann und das bedeutet
dass die Präsenz die wir bisher gesehen
haben in den östlichen Mitgliedstaaten
der NATO die ja sehr begrenzt war
ausgebaut werden muss damit sie
sozusagen eine verteidigungspräsenz ist
und damit sozusagen von Anfang an das
mögliche rote möglichen russischen
kalkulos verändert ist überhaupt erst zu
versuchen und das sind Schritte die die
NATO jetzt in den nächsten Wochen und
Monaten gehen wird und ansonsten ist
natürlich momentan das sind 70 Prozent
75 Prozent der russischen Armee gebunden
in der Ukraine aber die politischen
Forderungen die sind aufgestellt worden
diese Vertrag sind Würfe aus dem letzten
Jahr
bezogen sich nicht nur auf die Ukraine
die bezogen sich auch auf NATO
Mitgliedstaaten auch auf die Präsenz
US-amerikanische Nuklearwaffen in Europa
das heißt wir sollten uns immer
bewusst sein dass es hier Russland nicht
nur um die Ukraine geht das ist kein
regionaler Krieg es geht um sich
sozusagen im Moment für die kommende
Zeit haben wir offenbar eine
Konzentration auf den Kriegsschauplatz
Ukraine war der vergangene Freitag ein
Wendepunkt in Brüssel haben sich die
Nato-Verteidigungsminister getroffen ich
habe es gesagt die NATO an sich wird
keine Waffen liefern aber die Länder
haben versprochen zu liefern was nötig
ist das Thema defensivwaffen diese
Einschränkung scheint vom Tisch zu sein
ist das einfach nur eine Ankündigung
oder ein Wendepunkt im Verhalten der
NATO-Länder naja es ist zumindest in der
Hand was die Ankündigung am betrifft ist
das an Wendepunkt und wahrscheinlich
hoffentlich wird es da auch Konsequenzen
geben aber es ist ja eines von vielen
Wendepunkten in dem in den vergangenen
Wochen und Monaten und es ist so ein
bisschen so dass
dass die NATO-Staaten ungefähr das
machen was Präsident selinsky was die
ukrainische Seite fordert nur immer mit
einem Verzug von mehreren Wochen oder
Monaten es musste und gerade was die
Bundesregierung anbetrifft wir erinnern
uns dass es gar nicht so lange her dass
wir da 5000 Helme hingeliefert haben
weil wir dachten Protein ist da nur zum
die russische Picknick an die
unheimliche Grenze ausgerückt und es
musste erst der erste Überfall passieren
genau
keine überfallen dass die
Bundesregierung sich bereit erklärt hat
überhaupt ein paar Raketen und defensive
Waffen zu liefern und jetzt nach Butcher
ist dann der nächste Schritt passiert
nicht glaube man könnte der Ukraine
glaube ich wäre gut viel geholfen wenn
die NATO einfach früher das machen würde
wenn worum es die Präsident Zielinski
bitte das ist ein bisschen das sind das
ist etwas Platte Formel aber ich so so
läuft so was ist denn die letzten Monate
und ich glaube das könnte eine Lösung
sein aber guck mal
wer sein Außenminister also selenskys
Außenminister Dimitri Kollegah war in
Brüssel am Freitag und der hat das sehr
sehr klar formuliert
I came here with a simple message
for the discussion
weapons and weapons er sagt ich bin mit
einer klaren Botschaft gekommen Frau
Körbel ich habe nur drei Forderungen die
heißen trinken Sie nur die drei
Forderungen heißen Waffen Waffen
unterstellen wir mal das jetzt ein ganz
starkes Bemühen um Waffenlieferungen
beginnt was kann das bewirken was würde
der letzte Freitag auslösen wenn diese
Ankündigung umgesetzt werden ich glaube
dass ein ganz fundamentales Umdenken
gerade stattfindet also ja youtube ist
empört darüber dass das nicht sofort
geht tatsächlich glaube ich dass wir
auch ein bisschen der Krieg geht fort
schreitet fort und hat seine
Erfordernisse aber irgendwie müssen wir
auch von diesen friedensmodus in
Dornröschenschlaf in dem wir uns
offensichtlich befunden haben auf eine
auf eine ganz neue Situation einstellen
die vermutlich jetzt anfängt und noch
lange anhalten wird und ich
habe auch verständ dafür dass das nicht
von heute auf morgen geht auch wenn die
5000 Helme wirklich einen Witz waren ich
glaube dass die Defense die die die die
Frage ob das jetzt Defensive oder
Offensive machen sind das ist völlig vom
Tisch man hat man qualifiziert jetzt was
brauchen die und zwar was ich weiß ob
das jetzt schützen für einen Panzer sind
oder ob das Abwehrsysteme sind
abwehrraketensysteme sind da geht es
eigentlich mehr darum jetzt um die
Logistik wie können wir das was wir
haben wie kriegen wie kriegen wir das
ran was die brauchen und wie können wir
das was wir haben dahin bringen was ich
was da gibt es wirklich logistische
Probleme angefangen davon dass das
Handbuch von irgendwelchen
Schützenpanzern nicht in kyrillisch
sondern eben in englisch oder deutsch
oder was auch immer oder Französisch
geschrieben ist bis solche profanen
Dinge sind das manchmal ja
wie kriegt man die da rein dann zum
Beispiel man kann auch nicht einfach
Waffensysteme liefern und sagen fahr mal
los mit dem Leo das geht einfach nicht
sondern es dauert ungefähr ein Jahr oder
ein halbes Jahr ja bis man so ein
Waffensystem beherrscht also es heißt es
geht darum dass man passende
Waffensysteme die zum Beispiel aus dem
Sowjet aus also derzeit noch kommen das
passiert jetzt gerade eben mit den
tschechischen oder mit dem tschechischen
Panzer oder mit den
slowakischen Abwehrsystem es muss auch
irgendwie passend gemacht werden sowas
geht auch nicht einfach über Nacht ja es
ist auch problematisch und zwar
politisch erstmal muss man muss es
verdaut und katalysiert werden und und
und praktisch muss es durchgeführt
werden das passiert aber jetzt ich habe
keinen Zweifel mehr ich glaube offensiv
defensiv ist vollkommen vom Tisch es
passiert NATO wird versuchen oder NATO
will sich raushalten keinen Fuß
sozusagen in ukrainisches Hoheitsgebiet
und gleichzeitig kriegen die alles was
Sie brauchen für diese Schlacht aber die
jetzt bevorsteht
diese Schlacht die jetzt bevorsteht
dafür kommt das jetzt also ich halte
fest der politische Wille ist
ausgedrückt sie halten ihn auch für
glaubwürdig jetzt gibt aber viele da
würde ich immer widersprechen weil ich
ich will jetzt von Kosovo und
Afghanistan wo die Bundeswehr 20 Jahre
lang in einem Krieg verwickelt weil ich
gar nicht reden sondern allein wenn wir
uns diese Bundesregierung anschauen ich
glaube wenn es jemand unter wenn eine
Partei da in einem Dornröschen Schlaf
finde ich da auch ein bisschen finde ich
sehr wohlwollend also wer unwillig war
das war die SPD ich glaube wenn die also
wenn wir dieselbe Bundesregierung gehabt
hätten wenn aus der aus der
Bundestagswahl Unterführung der Grünen
hätten wir schon wäre diese wäre dieses
tun sie natürlich interessant ich wir
sprechen
gleich nach Deutschland ich versuche
noch mal die Lage also wir sind bei der
bei der NATO beim politischen Willen und
ich verspreche Ihnen sind gleich dran
damit Leute zeigen ich würde gerne noch
ergänzen
zu dem was gerade gesagt wurde sind wir
wirklich aus aufgewacht aus diesem
Dornröschenschlaf es ist immer noch ein
Gedanke da auch in der deutschen Debatte
das ein Frieden und ein Waffenstillstand
die beste Variante ist hauptsache die
Waffen schweigen und danach ist Ruhe
aber wir müssen uns dessen bewusst
machen dass ein zu früher
Waffenstillstand für die Ukraine ein
unglaubliches Risiko darstellt weil es
bedeuten kann dass Russland einfach nur
eine Pause einlegt und dann in wenigen
Monaten oder Jahren wieder angreift und
zum anderen bedeutet das dass ein zu
früher Waffenstillstand zu russischen
Bedingungen bedeutet das Territorien
unter russischer Kontrolle bleiben und
wir haben jetzt gesehen dass das keine
Option sein kann für die ukrainische
Regierung weil in diesen Regionen eine
russische Schreckensherrschaft etabliert
wird und das ist etwas sozusagen eine
diplomatische Lösung ist wichtig und am
Ende wird es eine Verhandlungslösung
geben müssen aber die Frage ist zu
welchem Zeitpunkt ist sie richtig und zu
welchem Zeitpunkt ist die einfach nur
ein zu früh und ein Risiko für
zugespitzt heißt das sind dran aber ich
gebe die Frage mal mit zugespitzt heißt
das die Ukraine und auch der Westen sind
im Moment zu schwach für einen
Waffenstillstand wir müssen erst sag mal
aufrüsten Stärke zeigen
vielleicht auch also wir sage ich jetzt
die Ukraine mit westlicher Unterstützung
militärisch Vorankommen
das bedeutet es wäre ein bewusstes
befördern des Krieges sie haben ja nicht
die
mittelgebiete zurückzuerobern sie haben
nicht die Panzer die nötigen wenn man
sich anguckt jetzt selbst wenn die
Leopard Panzer irgendwann mal kommen sie
sagen ja das dauert auch die zu schulen
die Besatzung und so das sind ganz
anderes System als diese T-72 die sie
jetzt zum Beispiel aus Tschechien
bekommen und so das dauert sie kriegen
offenbar auch keine Kampfflugzeuge weil
es da eben schon noch diese Bedenken
gibt dass das irgendwie doch Offensive
Waffen sein und so da gab es ja diesen
Vorfall in Belgorod wo ein Öllager in
Russland in die Luft gesprengt wurde das
waren wohl die Ukrainer dann aber doch
dementiert das geht da offenbar genau
darum dass man eben diese Ängste der
NATO dass das irgendwie eskalieren
könnte doch auch aufgreift damit die
vielleicht doch noch die Flugzeuge
schicken wofür wo und da Scheunen die
jetzt noch vor zurück ne wenn die aber
eben nicht die Gebiete zurückerobern
können dann sieht man eben was passiert
ist in den Jahren seit 2014 auf der Krim
und im dornbuster gibt es ja wirklich
diese Terror-Regime wo Leute die sich
für eine ukrainische Eigenständigkeit
eine ukrainische Unabhängigkeit auch
eine ukrainische Sprache und Kultur
einsetzen einfach verschwinden oder zu
jahrelanger Lagerhaft verurteilt werden
und da wechselnden Vorwänden dann in
Russland so ist es auf der Krim zum
Beispiel und natürlich ist wirklich wie
Frau fix sagt das Risiko eben dass wenn
man jetzt sagt bloß macht es die Waffen
schweigen dass dann eben ein teuregim
sich zementiert in den besetzten
Gebieten und außerdem dann Russland
rekrutiert um dann doch noch Kiew und
rief und so weiter einzunehmen also es
ist überhaupt nicht sicher dass das dann
wirklich den Frieden irgendwie befördert
das heißt mit der Macht Aufbau einer
abschränkung oder
Verteidigungspositionen und mit einer
zeitlichen Vorstellung von mehreren
Jahren denn nachdem was Sie beschrieben
haben geht es ja um Systeme ich habe es
gelesen die man wenn es schnell geht
2024 oder so bekommt das heißt darauf
müssen wir uns einstellen dass wir und
dann komme ich zu der Psychologie auch
zur deutschen Wahrnehmung hier Joel das
heißt dass wir jetzt nicht in sechs
Wochen oder drei Monaten eine Situation
haben wo die Ukraine selbstbewusst sagen
kann jetzt machen den Waffenstillstand
sondern das ist wie lange dauern kann
also das Aufbauen einer solchen
Fähigkeit dauert im Zweifel bis alles
steht würde ich sagen irgendwas zwischen
zwei und fünf Jahren zwischen ja
zwischen zwei und fünf Jahren also
insofern kann man sich auf jeden Fall
einrichten dass das der Beginn einer
ganz langen Zellen Auseinandersetzung
sein wird deren teilen wir die ganze
Zeit auch sein werden ich muss mich
tatsächlich ein Stück weit korrigieren
Herr Schmidt hat das völlig richtig
gesagt also es gibt eine eine bestimmte
Art von Waffen
zur Verfügung zu stellen die auch im
Verbund
diese Eskalation herbeiführen können das
ist die denke in Berlin zumindest mal
also schützentanz
Kampfpanzer
plus eine Luftverteidigung Luftabwehr
die quasi schon schon russische
abschussbasen treffen kann auf
russischen Territorium das ist deren
Angst das heißt also das ist ein außer
Kontrolle geraten das das Krieges
außerhalb des Territoriums der Ukraine
das ist das was unbedingt jetzt aus
Berliner Sicht verhindert werden soll
wobei ich glaube hier geht es wirklich
um um die Fragen
[Musik]
was will man erreichen die
abstimmungsfragen aber grundsätzlich ist
der Wunsch die Ukraine zu befähigen dass
sie das dass sie dass sie diese diese
Gebiete zurückerobern kann irgendwann
mal der ist da weil der politische Wille
irgendwann mal ausgedrückt wurde
dass das
die Integrität der Ukraine darf nicht
darf nicht angegriffen werden ist
offenbar die politische Position der
NATO in Anführungszeichen und sicherlich
auch bestimmter Staaten innerhalb der
Nato und jetzt springen wir in unser
eigenes Land und an der Stelle sind sie
wieder dran herrgeschäft was ich danke
schön also ich glaube
ich habe gerade das Gefühl dass man so
ein bisschen in diesem kleinen
militärstrategischen Klang Klang von dem
ich zumindest nichts verstehe ich habe
nicht gedient das ist auch dass das kann
ich nicht das weiß ich nicht und ich
glaube wir sollten uns auch nicht in
diesem in diesem kleinen teiligen was
bestimmt das auch seine Berechtigung hat
aber darüber sollten mir finde ich nicht
vergessen wie die sozusagen die die
politischen großlinien und ich glaube
noch mal das war der Punkt wo ich eben
widersprechen wollte das ist finde ich
sehr verständnisvoll und sehr wohl und
gegenüber der Bundesregierung zu sagen
naja braucht ja ein bisschen Zeit und
das logistische dann so ist das also ich
glaube selbst diese Bundesregierung wenn
das unter der Bezahlung dieser drei
Parteien unter einer anderen Führung
nämlich unter der Führung der Grünen
Partei glaube ich wäre einiges viel
früher passiert also Robert Habeck hat
letztes Jahr schon äh da hat er noch in
seiner eigenen Partei noch Schelte
bekommen aber er hat letztes Jahr schon
die dieses das ins Gespräch gebracht
dass das Deutschland auch in die Ukraine
mit Waffen in die Ukraine liefern sollte
Ende letzten Jahres war das ist das ist
drei Monate vier Monate jetzt her dass
Olaf Scholz noch bei Nord Stre dabei
eine unpolitische Lösung wollte und
jetzt ich sehe das nicht ich sehe das
vorhin bei der SPD nicht die SPD hat das
ist wohl viele Traditionslinien Willy
Brandt und was weiß ich was da noch
alles an der Rolle spielt aber es ist
vor allem die SPD die sich auch
innerhalb dieser Bundesregierung von den
Grünen treiben lassen muss die für sich
von der westlichen Partnern treiben
lassen muss aber ich sehe bei der SPD
ich glaube wenn das wenn das nach dem
Kanzler gegenüber wäre genauso eine
Lösung eher heute als morgen unter
welchen Bedingung auch immer aber
Hauptsache Frieden und noch mal einen
Schritt weiter wenn die Ukraine nach
2014 nach der mal dann Revolution in die
NATO aufgenommen worden wäre dann hätten
wir diese Situation nicht dann hätte sie
ganz ehrlich das ist eine ganz
eindeutige Sache also deswegen auch die
Frage wo wo könnte Putin als nächstes
angreifen naja ist wirklich glaube eher
nicht das Baltikum und eher nicht nicht
Polen weil die in der Natur sind und man
Darwin ist nicht in der in der NATO oder
georgien ist nicht in der NATO und das
ist ein ganz grundsätzlicher Punkt hätte
hätte der besten
nicht 20 Jahre lang mit auch auf Putin
versucht an einer eine Politik des der
der Befriedigung und das das ist aber
große Teile
Deutschland das ist ja nicht so dass die
westliche Welt in der letzten 20 Jahren
gegenüber Russland sehr Forscher
aufgetreten wäre und jetzt diese
Reaktion bekommt sondern ganz im
Gegenteil ist die Bundesrepublik Teil
der Strategie und des Vorgehens dass wir
beschrieben haben oder Bremssystem
momentan hat man den Eindruck das
gebremst wird und das zumindest nicht
alles in der Schnelligkeit getan wird
und auch in der
sozusagen
Umgehung der Bürokratie die eigentlich
nötig wäre also es gab ein sehr schönes
Interview mit der ethischen
Ministerpräsidenten die sagte in Estland
braucht es zwei Schritte um
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
freizugeben in Deutschland 18 Schritte
das natürlich ein riesiger Unterschied
und woran man das besonders gut
festmachen kann ist an der
internationalen Wahrnehmung wie nehme
ich die internationale Wahrnehmung
Deutschlands einfach wie in einem Pegel
immer wieder schwankt von großem
Misstrauen und Skeptizismus Januar
diesen Jahres zu Lob für die zeitenwände
und jetzt wieder zurück zwei Schritte
vor ein Schritt zurück und das ist eine
das kreiert ein Gefühl der
Unzuverlässigkeit bei unseren Partnern
oder ein Gefühl dass man Deutschland
vielleicht doch nicht in allem vertrauen
kann was für uns ein was für Deutschland
ein großes politisches Risiko ist wenn
unsere östlichen Nachbarstaaten das
Gefühl bekommen es ist irgendwie immer
wackelig also es passiert zwar was aber
Präsident Schritt zurückgenommen am Ende
fallen müssen sich unsere Nachbarn
darauf verlassen können dass Deutschland
ein Partner ist für Ihre Sicherheit und
momentan gucken sie ganz stark in die
USA gucken sie ganz stark nach
Großbritannien aber gucken mit großer
Skepsis nach Deutschland und vielleicht
mit noch größerer Skepsis nach
Frankreich eine der Fragen die Sie
besonders beschäftigt danke wir
verfolgen was sie uns zurückschreiben in
den Livestreams bei Tagesschau und
Presseclub und gerade diese Frage sie
haben den Zustand oder Sie haben es
beschrieben und
die Frage bei einigen Nutzerinnen und
Nutzern ist warum ist das so warum ist
die Kommunikation so verwirrend warum
lassen wir einfach USA und
Großbritannien vorangehen und liefern
nicht selber schnell damit
an mich die Frage ja ich glaube das
hängt mit Deutschland zusammen ich bin
natürlich Russland Korrespondent aber
ich habe in den vergangenen Jahren immer
wieder gemerkt dass in Deutschland halt
die Befindlichkeiten einfach
entsprechend sind man möchte halt gerne
weil die Geschichte so grauenhaft ist
dass alles harmonisch ist und um den
Preis des Wegsehens von Problemen um den
Preis ist Wegsehens von den
Menschenrechtsverletzungen auf der Krim
und im Don Bass und so weiter und klar
hat ja gesagt und Frau Kölbl es ist eine
Zeitenwende auch einen Erwachen aus den
Dornröschen schlafen den man sich
eigentlich all die Jahre lang ja selbst
eingelöst hat und das ist einfach
braucht eine Zeit und ich glaube in
Amerika in den Vereinigten Staaten
Großbritannien ist da einfach eine ganz
andere hemdärmlichkeit im Umgang mit
solchen Fragen weil das die Sieger des
Zweiten Weltkriegs sind
noch hier kein hippiland also jemand
Deutschland beliefert beliebt ist noch
also die Jungs von Rheinmetall sind auch
keine Hippies also Deutschland beliefert
seit Jahren auf
also saut ein Land wie Saudi Arabien
wird von Deutschland aufgerüstet also
ich finde dieses Dornröschen Schlaf
Geschichte ich finde also Blick auf
Russland aber das ist dann nicht dort
Dornröschenschlaf und nicht nicht
deutsches
deutsches hippietum oder so sondern das
ist mit ganz bestimmte Haltung gegenüber
Russland was glaube ich das Problem
also ich finde die Frage gespannt also
warum ich ich führe noch mal aus es kann
ja sein dass es vernünftige Zweifel gibt
an dem Vorgehen auf dass ich die
Mehrheit der NATO-Staaten
verständigt hat dass diese Zweifel in
der deutschen Öffentlichkeit deutschen
Politik stärker sind dann wäre es ja gut
zu zögern und abzuwägen oder die
Strategie ist eigentlich beschlossen man
findet sie richtig und es fehlt die
Kraft in Deutschland also warum warum
sind wir da in einer anderen Rolle ich
halte das für eine für eine
traditionelle unerwachsenheit die wir
haben oder ist die wir als Deutsche
haben und das ist eine Mischung aus wir
sind groß wir sind relativ mächtig die
Bundeswehr ist zwar in entsetzlichem
Zustand aber wir sind relativ Einfluss
Gespräch wenn es wenn es darum geht
Finanzierungen vorzunehmen
Entscheidungen mitzutragen wir sind
wichtige Partner für die Amerikaner wir
sind wir sind wichtig in diesem in
diesem Konzert Europas und der NATO in
Europa gleichzeitig haben haben die
Deutschen nie wirklich souveräne
Entscheidungen getroffen sondern sie
sind immer Teil eines Verbundes gewesen
mussten immer zum Jagen getragen werden
und diese es ist einfach verlernt für
die eigene Sicherheit einzustehen für
die Sicherheit der Architektur in Europa
selbst einzustehen ich würde mal sagen
es fehlt sogar das Vokabular dafür was
verteidigen wir denn also ich habe ich
habe lange über diese Kriege im
mittelost und in Afghanistan sonst wohne
auf dem Balkan berichtet Balkan war
schon ziemlich nahe aber da hat man sich
gesagt naja die müssen sich jetzt da
finden das sind irgendwelche ethnischen
Geschichten und dann treten wir den
Brand da aus und dann und dann und dann
und dann ist da wieder Ruhe und es war
auch beherrschbar in Afghanistan hatten
wir schon ganz große Bauchschmerzen
Kritik aha also da wird jetzt am
Hindukusch die Freiheit unsere Freiheit
das war nicht stimmig hier ist es
stimmig hier ist es so dass in Ukraine
die Freiheit Europas und auch der
Bundesrepublik verteidigt wird und das
muss aber erst einsinken und dafür muss
man erst
Vokabular und das und die zugehörige und
die dazugehörige
intellektuelle
Ausformulierung quasi etablieren das ist
aber nie geschehen darüber haben wir nie
gesprochen und vielleicht um deiner
kurze ergänzen tatsächlich ist aber
momentan nicht die deutsche Bevölkerung
das Problem also die deutsche
Bevölkerung denkt die letzten Umfragen
zu 45 Prozent dass die Bundesregierung
nicht genug tut und auch in Umfragen zum
Energie embargo sind ungefähr die Hälfte
der Deutschen befürworten das also jetzt
haben wir tatsächlich eine Situation und
wo eigentlich die Umfragen in der
Bevölkerung sogar weitergehen als das
wie die sozusagen die Position der
Bundesregierung ich
will Samstag noch mal sacken lassen weil
ich das Gefühl habe also keiner und
keine am Tisch hat vernünftige Zweifel
daran dass es notwendig ist
gegenüber Russland militärische Kraft
aufzubauen abzuschrecken eine mögliche
Verteidigung aufzubauen was wir im
Moment die Ukraine tun lassen
damit das ganze nicht näher kommt und
die NATO-Staaten ist selbst tun müssen
also so habe ich zumindest ich will dass
meine sehr Deutlichkeit festhalten so
habe ich diese Diskussion verstanden
dann ist die eine Frage die der
Bewaffnung da haben wir gerade
besprochen wie lange das dauern kann wie
kompliziert das ist das ist keine Frage
weniger Wochen ist dass sie haben es
gerade erwähnt Frau fix was ja
scheinbar schnell wirksam radikal und
sofort möglich ist ist das Thema
Sanktionen da gibt es allerlei lange
Liste von dem was passiert ist aber wir
haben es in der Tagesschau eben gehört
Herr selenski fordert Öl embargo sofort
meine Frage was ist wirksamer Herr
Schmidt Waffen oder Sanktionen ich
glaube Waffen es ist beides wirksam aber
die Sanktionen die Waffen wirken sofort
je nachdem was für Waffen es sind
natürlich aber ohne diese
Panzerabwehrwaffen diese javellins zum
Beispiel
sie die Lage da heute sicher ganz anders
aus die Sanktionen die sind eine Sache
die
mittelfristig bestenfalls wirken je
nachdem was für Sanktionen ist dann sind
wirken sie mehr oder weniger jetzt hat
man Kohle beschlossen die EU will keine
russische Kohle mehr einführen das
bringt nicht so besonders viel die Kohle
verkaufen sie sowieso schon zu großen
Teilen nach Asien vor allem nach China
kann sie ganz leicht auf der Schiene aus
zentral Sibirien dahin transportieren
Öl dafür darüber wird jetzt diskutiert
mit Öl haben sie mehr verdient als mit
Gas zum Beispiel Öl können Sie aber auch
anderweitig verkaufen eben über Frachter
diese rumschippern wie man jetzt hört
ist es offenbar so dass das russische Öl
schon jetzt nur mit Abschlägen auf dem
Weltmarkt verkauft werden kann zum
Beispiel nach Indien aber Sie können es
noch verkaufen mit Gas ist es so eine
Sache das ist natürlich in Deutschland
ein sehr heikles Thema aber Gas können
sie zu großen Teilen wirklich nur nach
Westen verkaufen nach Europa in die
Türkei wegen der Pipelines das können
sie sonst nicht loswerden deswegen wäre
Gas in gewisser Weise das wirksamste
und vielleicht dazu ergänzend der
EU-Außenbeauftragte Borell hat zwei
Zahlen in den Raum geworfen dass seit
Beginn des Krieges 35 Milliarden Euro an
Russland gezahlt worden sind für Energie
und eine Milliarde Euro direkt an
militärischer Hilfe an die Ukraine also
um nur noch einmal die Dimensionen zu
vergleichen die dort die dort vonstatten
gehen und ich glaube wir müssen die
Debatte über Energie Sanktionen auch
sozusagen intellektuell ehrlich führen
also es ist natürlich eine Sache zu
argumentieren dass das der eigenen
Wirtschaft schade das ist der
europäischen Wirtschaft schadet dann
muss man sozusagen in Kauf nehmen dass
die langfristigen Folgen wenn man das
nicht tut die akzeptieren aber es gibt
auch Argumente die sagen nein so ein Öl
oder Gaseinbau würde nichts bringen und
das stimmt natürlich nicht das hätte
einen massiven Einfluss auf den
russischen Staatshaushalt nicht so zu
damit würde nicht der Krieg von einem
Tag auf den anderen enden aber es würde
Russlands finanzielle Möglichkeiten
unglaublich beschränken und es ist auch
so schmerzhaft das wäre ist es auch
Investition eine langfristige
Investition in unsere eigene Sicherheit
weil es Russland die finanziellen
Ressourcen nehmen würde um wie auch
immer dieser Krieg ausgehen wird danach
wieder die Wirtschaft aufzubauen und
wieder sein eigenes Militär aufzubauen
und für Europa eine Bedrohung
darzustellen und deswegen ist es ein
nicht nur ein kurzfristiges
mittelfristiges wirtschaftliches
Argument sondern ein langfristiges
Kalkül über das hier nachgedacht werden
muss ich habe noch eine Idee das ist
viel ungefährlicher als eine
Flugverbotszone macht uns auch nicht
bringt uns nicht in Gewissenskonflikte
mit mit Waffen kein Gas kostet nichts
warum hat Deutschland noch mal die EU
jetzt wie lange sind das jetzt sechs
Wochen gebraucht bis Ursula von der
Leyen jetzt vorgestern in Kiew gesagt
hat ja die die Ukraine könnte sein dass
wir die Ukraine als beitrittskandidatin
akzeptieren warum also eine Maßnahme
eine Solidarität das ist ja auch so ein
Wort das so viel im Raum ist das ist ja
kein leeres Wort und das hat eine
praktische Ebene aber es hat auch
chronische Ebene nämlich adressiert an
die Menschen in der Ukraine und so eine
Erklärung was noch zielinsky auch ein
paar mal gesagt aber was an eine
Botschaft an die Ukraine gewesen wäre
und das wäre eine passende Botschaft
gewesen weil ich glaube da wird nicht
nur die Freiheit Europas mit
verteidigten Ukraine ja dass man es wird
auch die Idee von Europa verteidigt und
die Ukraine ist das einzige Land wenn
wir zurückblicken auf die letzten zehn
Jahre das war für Europa überall in
allen Ländern ein schlechtes Jahrzehnt
von der von der Eurokrise über die
flüchtlingskrise zum brexit überall
Kräfte die EU aus der EU raus wollen und
die EU hat diesen Glanz den man diese
Ausstrahlungskraft die man die man man
hatte noch um die Jahrtausendwende und
die Ukraine ist das einzige Land in
Europa also ich kenne kein zweites wo
die Menschen auf die Straße gegangen
sind wo sie wo sie erschossen wurden
muss ermordet wurden auf der bei der
Mandan Revolution für die Orientierung
in Richtung Europa und das Ergebnis ist
das Europa nicht nur und dass die europ
Führungsmächte nämlich Deutschland und
Frankreich nicht nur bei der praktischen
Sachen bei
Wirtschaftssanktionen nicht mitmachen
weil bei den bei der Waffen sich
irgendwie beim bei der Militärhilfe sich
tragen lassen mussten sondern selbst bei
so einer symbolischen Sache die die
lassen sie uns oberbeitritt ich finde
selbst
dabei das wollen sie nicht und ich und
meine Befürchtung ist dahinter steckt
der Glaube dass man wenn das wird schon
irgendwie schnell vorbei gehen und dann
wird man mit Putin sich wieder in einen
Tisch sitzen können das glaube ich nicht
mit Putins will man sich nicht mal an
einen Tisch setzen ich glaube das ist
wirklich vorbei ich kann auch ich kann
auch ihre ihre Wut und ihre Empörung
verstehen aber die EU und auch die NATO
sind keine One-Man Show sondern das sind
sehr das sind man muss sich auch finden
also es ist auch so dass Absprachen und
und Regularien irgendwie organisiert
werden müssen manchmal ist es so profan
ich würde gerne noch was sagen was was
die Gaslieferungen angehen und den Preis
den 13 zu bezahlen ich glaube darum geht
es wir sind bereit oder alle sind bereit
ihren Preis oder Ihren Beitrag
zuzuleisten oder in Preis dafür zu
bezahlen ich meine habe geht herum mit
Wirtschaftsminister habe ich so das
können wir uns nicht leisten dann weiß
ich was haben wir Massenarbeitslosigkeit
die Chemieindustrie bricht zusammen und
und
aber letztlich geht es darum was ist uns
das wert wie wie mit welchem Einsatz
wirtschaftlich militärisch politisch
gesellschaftlich wollen wir in diese in
diese in diesem Prozess investieren der
jetzt plötzlich mit diesem schrecklichen
Krieg begonnen hat ich glaube das sind
das sind Fragen die wir uns einfach
nicht gestellt haben und wir irgendwie
noch immer organisieren wie geht es
möglichst so weiter ja und mit möglichst
geringen Schaden für uns ich finde das
jetzt auch nicht
fürchterlich oder ich finde das jetzt
auch nicht total verwerflich aber man
kann sich diese Frage stellen ja aber
Fragen von enormer Tragweite
wir haben das gerade bei der
militärischen Aufstellung diskutiert das
würde ja auch für die Veränderung der
Märkte der Wirtschaft durch die
Sanktionen gelten also insofern klar ist
wie sie sagen das ist etwas was sehr
grundlegendes ich würde gern die letzten
Minuten ich würde gerne die letzten
Minuten
erklären das könnte die Bundesregierung
ja auch also alleine
den letzten
den letzten Durchgang dieser Sendung
noch mal auch mit Blick auf das was ich
so von ihren Reaktionen lese also wir
haben eine Welt beschrieben in der sich
der Westen mit der Ukraine zusammen
gegen Russland aufrüstet Abschreckung an
eine Linie zieht wir haben eine Welt
beschrieben in der sich
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen auflösen und
Russland isoliert wird mit Putin wird
man sich nicht mehr an einen Tisch
setzen hat gerade eben jemand gesagt
eine Frage die ich zum Beispiel bei Alex
lese der uns geschrieben hat
was ist denn wie können wir die wie
können wir die Kräfte in Russland
unterstützen die auf ein besseres
Russland nach Putin hinarbeiten also ist
das eine Vorstellung der Abtrennung
einer neuen Weltordnung auf alle Zeit
oder gibt es eine Perspektive nach Putin
und die Frage Russland einzubunden
binden ist vielleicht doch gar nicht so
absurd das vielleicht als kurze
Schlussrunde Herr schmidther es ist sehr
schwierig derzeit irgendwelche Kräfte in
Russland einzubinden weil einfach das
putinlager alle anderen Kräfte platt
macht auf deutsch gesagt
die NGOs da werden aufgelöst unabhängige
Journalisten haben zu Hunderten das Land
verlassen und jetzt sind gerade deutsche
Stiftungen da verboten worden diese
politischen Stiftungen die es gibt MS
die International wurde aufgelöst Human
Rights Watch also es ist sehr sehr
schwierig da mit jemandem Kontakt
aufzunehmen das Beste was jetzt der
Westen tun kann in dieser Lage ist
wirklich leicht Visa zu erteilen an
Russen die das Land verlassen möchten
den vielleicht auch irgendwie zu helfen
vielleicht auch irgendwelche
journalistischen Projekte zu fördern mit
Geld oder wie auch immer dass das
passiert im aus dem Ausland letztlich
danke ich versuche es noch mal mit der
bitte um kurze Antworten also der Blick
in eine fernere Zukunft ist Russland auf
alle Zeit abgehängt oder werden wir
wieder Brücken bauen auf keinen Fall
selbstverständlich schon sich einfach
die Karte an selbstverständlich müssen
wir mit Russland wieder Brücken bauen
also
nur ich fürchte momentan also das wird
sehr lange dauern das könnte sehr sehr
lange dauern ich sehe nicht dass es
nicht man sich mal mit Pute dann ein
Tisch setzt aber ist eigentlich er ist
kein Partner mehr ist ein paar mehr
geworden und danke
naja Diktatur keine Diktatur hält so
lang wie ist die Diktaturen gerne hätten
aber meistens sind sie doch zäher als
das die Demokraten sich wünschen
verflixt die Referenz die wir haben ist
der kalte Krieg auf dem wir uns
sozusagen zurückbesinnen konnten können
und auch im Kalten Krieg gab es Phasen
der Stabilisierung nach Phasen der
Eskalation wo auch hellsinki 75 wieder
möglich war aber das ist etwas für die
wirklich lange Zeit das ist etwas wo wir
in Dekaden denken und im Moment ist die
Frage inwiefern dieser Krieg vielleicht
der Anfang des Endes des putin-regimes
ist oder wie lange er sich denn
tatsächlich halten kann aber wir
befinden uns ganz klein an der Phase der
Eskalation die noch viele Jahre andauern
wird bevor wir möglicherweise wieder in
einem historische Phase der
Stabilisierung kommen können sie haben
auf die jetzt Zeit betrachtet
beantwortet als Russland Kenner wollen
sie noch mit zwei Sätzen einen Blick
weiter nach vorne wagen
ja es ist natürlich so dass es auch
Kräfte gibt Oppositionskräfte in
Russland zum Beispiel Alexander valny
der inhaftiert ist schon seit seiner
Rückkehr aus Deutschland wo er sich ja
von dem vergiftungsanschlag erholt hat
es gibt auch Oppositionelle die jetzt
ins Ausland geflohen sind die sind
natürlich jetzt noch marginal in
Russland man muss sagen dass es eine
große schweigende wohl Mehrheit gibt die
da irgendwie in einer Mischung aus
Apathie und Zustimmung dahinter steht
aber es kann natürlich sein dass ich in
Russland in den in den nächsten Jahren
wie auch immer da dann doch etwas ändert
mit ich wollte zumindest einen Funken
Optimismus ja haben sie geschafft so ein
Funken ich habe mir Mühe gegeben bedanke
mich sehr herzlich für diese sehr
grundlegende Debatte bedanke mich bei
Ihnen jetzt hier in der ARD das
europamagazin unter anderem mit einem
Blick auf Russlands Propaganda und bei
Phoenix und im Radio Presseclub
nachgefragt tschüss und lassen Sie es
gut gehen
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück Presseclub
nachgefragt im Radio WDR 5 im Fernsehen
bei Phoenix jetzt sind Sie dran und
zuerst in allen Westfalen Amelie Sanders
guten Tag liebe Frau Sanders willkommen
in der Sendung
[Applaus]
an den französischen Mädchen die sehr
viel konkreter sind als die Deutschen
und es werden dort von durchaus Russland
freundlichen Experten Politologen
militärex sein und so weiter wird die
Situation analysiert und folgendes zwei
Dinge zwei Punkte dich zur Kenntnis
geben möchte vielleicht auch zum
kommentieren
Herr Putin hält sich an gar nichts
bin ich die minimalsten
Schutzmaßnahmen für die Zivilbevölkerung
die Maßnahmen die festgeschrieben sind
im internationalen Kriegsrecht er
verstößt komplett dagegen das heißt es
unter der Hand wird das ist wohl so
üblich vor dem Gegner mitgeteilt da ist
eine zivile Schutzzone da sind auch
keine Militärs gar nichts das kann nicht
angegriffen werden dass sie so keine
Gefahr und genau das greift Herr Putin
an Punkt 1 Punkt 2
general tradigon ein hochkarätiger
General der französischen Armee sagte
Putin hat ja angekündigt wenn der Westen
weiter Waffen liefert und schwere was
nicht hat dann gibt's also eine
Katastrophe unsere
Katastrophe wo ist die Katastrophe man
muss mit Putin nur so reden man muss ihm
diese Sprache zeigen
es gibt noch ganz viele in der Leitung
sie haben sie haben ihren sie haben
ihren Punkt deutlich gemacht
genau das war das was Sie sagen wollen
danke für den Impuls ich würde sagen wir
lassen das einfach so stehen aber prima
dass sie dabei sind tschüss nach allen
und wir gehen weiter zu Lothar Stutz in
Lauenburg das ist in Niedersachsen
glaube ich drei ländereck
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern Niedersachsen und
Schleswig-Holstein habe ich ja Glück
gehabt also es war nicht ganz falsch
bitteschön ja also bevor ich meine
eigentliche Frage stelle muss ich für
meine Vorteile Vorrednerin auch noch ein
bisschen was dazu sagen aber wirklich
nur ein bisschen
erstmal finde ich dass wir diese
Situation selbst mit beigetragen haben
wir Deutschen indem wir uns seit dem
Jahr 2000 und wie immer und kritisch den
Amerikanern angeschlossener haben in
2014 als klarer wen die USA sich als
Opposition ausgesucht haben haben wir
trotzdem mitgemacht und an die falsche
Seite gestellt jetzt haben wir den Salat
in Anführungsstrichen wenn das etwas
natürlich weit untertrieben mit dem was
die ganzen Folgen was das alles mit sich
bringt jetzt kommt eine Frage
Anmerkung dazu natürlich dann auch noch
sagen es war auch keine gute Idee selbst
dass die russischen Medien
ausgeschlossen werden in dieser ganzen
ganzen Aktion weil selbst Reporter auch
weiterhin Zugang zu russischen Medien
das scheint mir so
lassen Sie mich doch mal aufzählen und
seien Sie so lieb stellen Sie uns jetzt
Ihre Frage weil ganz viele Zuhörern und
Zuhörer noch warten und ihre Vorrednerin
durfte
genau so langsam dran die NATO könnte ja
ihrerseits Angebote machen
indem sie ja
passt mal auf Liebe Russen wir machen
jetzt mal folgendes Angebot wir machen
jetzt ein Waffenstillstand und wir
verhandeln über den Status der Ukraine
ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen
blauäugig aber andererseits warum
dichtbar ist es sollten jetzt alle
Bemühungen gezogen werden anstatt dann
Waffen und Waffen Waffen Reifen
angekommen ich bedanke mich also die
Frage ist kann der besten kann die NATO
das in die Hand nehmen und mit Russland
verhandeln und ein Angebot machen wer
mag dazu ich glaube das ist ja genau das
was passiert ist vor Kriegsausbruch als
Russland so getan hat als ob sie
interessiert gewesen wären an
Verhandlungen und NATO ja auch
tatsächlich geantwortet hat sogar
schriftlich geantwortet hat auf die
russischen Forderungen und wir haben
gesehen dass das alles nur ein Manöver
von russischer Seite war um diesen Angel
geplanten Krieg durchzuführen und
vielleicht noch ergänzend dazu die USA
haben sich 2014 natürlich keine Partei
ausgesucht sondern es gab eine
Revolution auf dem maidanen die von
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern getragen worden
ist die die Zukunft der Ukraine und ihre
eigene politische Zukunft selbst
bestimmen wollten die russland hat sehr
klar gezeigt dass es nicht Interesse hat
an Verhandlungen sondern ein Krieg
führen möchte und seine politischen
Ziele mit Waffengewalt erreichen möchte
leider
ich würde sagen wir gehen weiter und
gehen zu Günter König nach München Herr
König schön dass Sie dabei sind gerne
Ihre Frage ja schönen guten Tag in die
Runde
es wurde jetzt viel Euphorie verbreitet
hinsichtlich der Erfolge der Ukraine in
der Verteidigung oder Rückeroberung
sogar vom Gebieten jetzt ist meine
Überlegung die hier nicht gestellt wurde
in der Runde wenn wir das weiterführen
und
schicken schicken die mit angriffswacht
und die Ukraine was jetzt vom Prinzip
nicht falsch wäre also in meiner Meinung
nur Putin hat einen Plan gehabt mit
einem Ziel
wenn es jetzt den ukrainen gelingt mit
konventionellen Waffen wie im Kiews
Umgebung die russischen Truppen aus den
besetzten Teilen vielleicht sogar auch
aus dem dornbass und der Krimi hinaus zu
prügeln
dann halte ich es für absolut
ausgeschlossen das Putin das geschehen
lässt nicht nur weil er ein Gesicht
waren will und nicht nur weil er ein
einen Plan hat
den das dann entgegen steht sondern weil
er völlig vernacht ist in die Idee
dieses russischen Reichs und der
unbegrenzten ja ich bin in dankbar weil
das glaube ich eine Frage ist die
eigentlich allen Beobachtern durch den
Kopf geht nicht also was wäre dann das
ist ja ihre Frage was wäre dann
potenzreaktion wie würde das enden ich
glaube das ist so schwer vorherzusehen
und ich glaube das ist auch ein
Unterschied weil wir alles vorhin auch
das Thema hatten wie war das mit früher
kalt Kalte Krieg ich glaube so die trotz
aller sauer töpfigkeit die diese
Breschnews hatten die hatten etwas
berechenbares was an Regime das
putin-regime nicht hat mit der Experte
aber ich glaube es ist auch nach
Kategorien wann hat der wann hätte der
was gewonnen gesichtswaren der kann doch
nicht also
ja scheint mir auch so und es könnte gut
sein dass wenn er sich jetzt auch mit
militärisch auch zurückgedrängt fühlt
kann ich glaube also ich weiß nicht wer
das ausschließen kann ich könnte das
nicht ausschließen das auch nicht zu
also auch zu zu APC machen
könnte aber das ist halt auch so
ich kann das ebenso wenig ausschließen
dass Putin einfach was was ich am 8 mai
der mag ja sowieso Daten am 8 mai
einfach erklärt die die spezialoperation
war erfolgreich und wir in dieser Daten
kann nach Hause also
Kategorien sogar rationale Kategorien
hat man
hier was gewonnen oder hatte verloren
und hat ein Gesicht dabei gewahrt oder
nicht ich glaube das ist so das sind
Kategorien eines eines rational auch
vor einer kritischen Öffentlichkeit
diesen Russland die Reste die ist noch
gab die werden gerade einkassiert
deswegen finde ich das schwierig mit so
einer mit so einer Sicherheit
vorherzusagen wie es weitergeht also es
könnte ich glaube beides man kann es
ausschließen weil dieses weil an diese
diese autokratische Regime ist nur nur
Kategorien der Vernunft agiert eine
existenzielle Frage also die Reaktion
einzukalkulieren und
also ich weiß nicht ob jemand anderer
Ansicht ist dass es rational
vorhersehbar ist ich würde vielleicht
nur ergänzen wollen dass natürlich Putin
damit auch dann spielt also speziell das
mit den Atomwaffen da drin ja zu Anfang
des Krieges gesagt dass die dass die
nuklearstreitkräfte in Bereitschaft
wären und so und der kokettiert immer
damit mit diesem Bild des verrückten der
bei jeder Gelegenheit den atomknopf
irgendwie dann da so zittert mit der
Hand und so und dann daraufhin lässt man
sich ins Bockshorn jagen und liefert zum
Beispiel keine Kampfflugzeuge oder so
und das ist natürlich so eine Sache wie
schätzt man seinen Charakter ein ich
würde sagen er ist nicht so suizidal
geprägt dass er so einen Atomschlag
riskieren würde wenn man also
taktische spekulieren aber ja wir haben
einfach den Finger an die Wunde gelegt
deshalb bedanke ich mich sehr herzlich
Herr König
nach München und ich greife mal aus dem
Gästebuch von Andreas Dahm die Frage auf
welche Möglichkeiten hätte ich China auf
Russland einzuwirken um sie dann eine
Vorstellung vergangen
also wenn überhaupt jemand eine
Möglichkeit hat und es ist Kita und
China ist im Grunde natürlich
interessiert dass die dass das dieser
dieser Krieg Europa schwächt und auch
möglichst auch die Europäer von den
Amerikanern entfremdet das findet
momentan nicht statt deshalb würde ich
eher sagen nach dem China
sich glaube ich mit diesem mit diesen
auch mit diesen Krieg nicht
identifizieren kann mit dem ja nichts zu
gewinnen ist diese Bilder sind so
grauenhaft das Russland eigentlich kein
bevorzugter Partner sein kann trotzdem
strategisch sind sie auf einer Linie ich
würde eher denken dass sie
ich würde eher denken dass sie einen
mäßigen denn Einfluss haben was das
Handling dieses Krieges angeht aber
gleichzeitig
gleichzeitig sie Russland und Putin
weiter stützen danke wir gehen weiter
mit ihnen mit Klaus Kirchner in Essen
hallo guten Tag ihre Frage oder
anmerkung
ja guten Tag
nach meiner Meinung wird viel zu viel
geredet bei den politischen
Verantwortlichen es müsste mehr
gehandelt werden
letztendlich liegt doch daran dass wir
jetzt zu viel Pazifisten im Moment wohl
an der Regierung haben wie Frau
Lambrecht die nur die die
Waffenlieferung verhindert ich finde es
auch im Skandal dass hier
Putin Demonstranten auftreten können
darüber wird auch diskutiert warum geht
man da nicht gegen vor und man könnte
diesen beiden fortsetzen warum wird so
lasch gehandelt und nicht
Forscher vorgegangen
das ist eigentlich
ja Anregung Frage wir brauchten
eigentlich ich sag mal diese hundertste
Meinung von Herrn Scholz
wir müssen ja Solidarität ich kann es
nicht mehr hören
in die Fragen bei ihrem Meinung ihre
Position deutlich eingeflossen möchte
jemand reagieren und wir so stehen
lassen als vielleicht zu dem Teil mit
den Demonstranten naja weil wir nicht
Russland sind ja also ganz einfach und
das sollten wir auch nicht und das ist
das sollten wir auch nicht werden wir
sind keine autokratisches Regime und das
Demonstrationsrecht gilt hierfür
jedermann und das ist auch gut so danke
Herr Kirchner dann gehen wir nach
Sprendlingen in Rheinhessen Ingolstadts
guten Tag Herr Staats sie sind dran
ja mich würde mal interessieren ob
jemand in der Runde erklären kann warum
die Politik nicht bereit ist für vier
Monate den gesamten privaten Verbrauch
an Gas auf Null zu stellen man will die
Industrie abschalten ich halte das
komplett für falsch ich glaube wir alle
müssen unsere Warmwasserbereitung und
die gesamte Gasheizung für vier Monate
auf Nullstellen und das Gas in den
vorratsspeichern belassen danke schön
danke
die Frage war ob jemand sagen kann warum
wir das nicht tun
bei der Endverbraucher Priorität hat
also das ist sozusagen die Tatsache dass
der Staat seine Bürgerinnen und Bürger
schützt und ihn sozusagen eine eine
warme Wohnung stellt ist ist sozusagen
prioritär über der Wirtschaft und ist
auch so festgelegt in diesen Gas
prioritätsplänen das ändert dadurch
nichts daran das ist schon sinnvoll ist
so wie habe ich das auch gemacht hat
dazu aufzurufen dass jetzt nicht die
Zeit ist verschwenderisch umzugehen mit
Energie wenn ich die Frage mal so
umdeute also der Vorschlag von den
Staats war jetzt radikal aber ich habe
im Moment nicht das Gefühl dass ich
tagtäglich wann morgens bis abends mich
mit der Frage auseinandersetzen muss das
ist große Appelle politische
Aufforderungen gibt
ist das nur meine Wahrnehmung oder wäre
da mehr drin
lassen wir stehen und
gehen ja wohin gehen wir noch wir gehen
nach Berlin zu Christel Weiher guten Tag
ja schönen
guten Tag ja einen schönen guten Tag an
die Runde ich habe mal folgende Frage
und zwar interessiert mich
was wir sind dran wir hören uns so mein
Mann hat mich gerade unterbrochen also
es geht darum strafvoll unglaublich ja
das soll Aufgaben und Öl das würde doch
Putin treffen würde kein total embargo
sein würde uns Geld in die Kasse spülen
und meine Frage ist warum die
Europäische Union das nicht gemeinsam
auf den Weg bringt
aber die Strafzölle müssten wir die wir
nutzen ja bezahlen
[Musik]
danke Abhandlung da es kann ich jetzt
nicht alles ausführen aber das ist das
ist ja sehr flexible handhabbar und wir
müssen ja sowieso auch in Tribute zahlen
und bringen und meine Frage ist wirklich
warum das so wenig auch in den
Diskussionsrunden im Fernsehen und sonst
vor diskutiert wird tatsächlich ist es
ist etwas was auch
kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
erwähnt hat das sozusagen importielle
gezahlt werden müssten die sozusagen an
Deutschland die dann wiederum zum
Beispiel weitergegeben werden könnten an
die Ukraine was sozusagen einer von
diesen Möglichkeiten wäre nicht ein
völliges Öl und Gas im Bahnhof von heute
auf morgen zu machen sondern zumindest
kreativ und graduell darüber
nachzudenken ohne sich nur an unsere
Timeline zu richten und das andere sind
Treuhandkonten konnten die erwähnt
worden sind von der
kommissionspräsidentin und die auch
diskutiert werden als eine Möglichkeit
um nicht von heute auf morgen ein
Boykott zu machen aber zumindest die
nicht weiter den russischen
Staatshaushalt zu finanzieren also das
eine Möglichkeiten die tatsächlich auch
diskutiert werden gerade
wir haben glaube ich auch weiterhin
debattenbedarf Waffenlieferungen sind
ein kompliziertes Thema wo man glaube
ich ein bisschen Expertise haben muss
Energieverbrauch der uns alle trifft das
haben wir gerade auch in den Fragen
gemerkt ist etwas was wir glaube ich
Vorentscheidungen auch in der
Gesellschaft breit diskutieren und
vermitteln müssen das war ein Teil davon
heute bedanke mich herzlich bedanke mich
bei der Runde hier am Tisch wünsche
Ihnen ja einen guten Start in die
Osterferien wenn sie welche haben in
einen sommerlicheren april als in den
letzten Tagen tschüss und lassen Sie es
gut gehen
[Musik]
Frankreich Welt wer regiert in Zukunft
die Grand Nation der amtierende
Präsident Emmanuel macron strebt eine
zweite Amtszeit an doch gegen Kandidaten
kommen von rechts und links wie stehen
seine Chancen das ganze Bild der
Präsidentschaftswahl in Frankreich live
aus Paris heute ab 18 Uhr bei Phoenix
vor Ort